hello everyone thanks for the
introduction
so the web is not too old we've been
using it for about 30 years now but it's
been constantly evolving over time so
we've seen different ways of creating
content different ways of using it and
also different devices of using the web
for example HTTP was introduced in 1991
and then after that we've seen things
like for example juice which allowed
people to upload websites online without
having to know what a server is and that
was something it was a thing for me was
the start of the web as we see it now
and then in 1999 in 2000 we had
something called like web 2.0 which is
can a second version of the web where
the focus would be more on
user-generated content so you see lots
of blogs and personal website and canned
electricity but a bigger scale so
everyone in the world would do it it was
not something that was only in the
States and also we've seen rest and soap
which are technologies have been used to
allow different services to communicate
to you together and also we're now using
them to have clients application
communicated with the backend and
especially rest we can believe any
popular and I think it's a beautiful
concept so you use HTTP and use HTTP
verbs to the operation of your resources
so for example you can do a get get a
list of course you can do a post and
create a new post or change it then you
can delete and post to create for
example new comment and there is also
patch and some other stand on
non-standard ones and it's really nice
and in 2004 we've seen apps like Gmail
in Google app Google Maps that were
basically pushing the boundaries of the
web the word web could be this is 2004
like it was something really really
different saying this application
running on a browser and you could do
things without having to refer refresh
the page and it was very powerful and
then in 2006 6 we seen Facebook tab then
became a global scale such a network and
this is quite important because they
start having problems the normally you
wouldn't have because he's a star
like billions a user thousand millions
on different devices and also problem is
like network and also low bandwidth and
so on then in 2007 another important
change was the iPhone followed by
Android devices and this would mark a
shift in the way we we build
applications for for the web we start
having mobile web sites and mobile
applications and the current days the
web is still evolving so we don't have
collections or document anymore but we
have ups and this apps are not simple
application there are really complex
even for a simple website like my
website was a single page application
which seemed simple but you still have
as an API behind and it's it's complex
is not just HTML and CSS and he also
makes sense to build applications now
instead of just static website because
in the developer experience much much
nicer than what it was before so we
serve creating api's is api's to
particular allow like a client to
communicate with a back-end also
communicate between different backends
or just even if in a stop where you
could have a front-end team and a
back-end team and sorry and you would
have api's to basically connect them
together instead of building like a
monolith for example the rest became in
industry standard at least in the non
enterprise world but it really didn't
scale with time while it still makes
sense for some use cases you still have
some issues like for example under
fetching which basically means you do a
request and then you have to do more
requests to get more data or the other
data you need for example you have a a
blog post where you will not get
information about the author by the
author for example is a link to the
author so you need to do another get to
to fetch the information the solution
for this would be to create a new
endpoint where you get all the data but
then you have issues like over fetching
where you send me way too much data to a
client that's basically not needed and
think for me the other issue that was
really painful is way too many endpoints
remember it's imagine if you have one
under resources' you who need to do at
least one under your routes and points
and weed I also need to documentation to
add documentation to to basically
document all the end points that you
have all the way so you can use those
end points filters and so on well you
have some tools especially important to
try to making documentation is still
painful because there are this bit of
manual work to do
so we start looking for some
alternatives and we are thinking what if
the clients that we have to declare the
data that we need that they need so
let's say we have a client I mean
something like this so it needs a list
of categories and for each category
needs a name
we could send a document like this
saying you know I need the category and
the name which this is basically like a
JSON but doesn't have the values so we
would send this to the back end and the
back end respond with the this and this
is but basically what graph Kelly's
graphical is a query language and it's
being created by Facebook in 2012 and
every source of Windows in 2015 and it's
been used now in production by Twitter
github and loads of other so I think we
read it as well and it can be used with
HTTP it doesn't have to so you can use a
WebSocket as well or any other protocols
if you need to in the case of HTTP there
is one me one endpoint a new center
dated arm it's under document here to
request the data that you want so you do
something like this and she people /ql
and you send something like this and you
get back the data you asked for and for
example if you want to ask for more
information you can do it just change
the shape of your document and then the
response is going to be this one in
based on what you asked for it also as a
type so I have a graphical app API as a
schema and a schema basically solves the
type that you have and all the fields
that you have for each type so for
example in the previous API we have a
type query which is the root of our API
so the fields are coming from their
query and then in this case we have a
category which is a list of categories
then we have
category which has a name and then a
list of menu items then many items on
their name and a description and then a
we having all this together it basically
allows you to us to use tools like this
one to basically have an easy way to get
the documentation and do testing for
example let's see if I can get today so
we can see the schema that we had before
and we can also see the documentation so
in so for example you can see we have a
list of previous year
there is only one categories and then
the type is category and then there's
names English so you can explore the API
like this without having to basically
write any code or check the actual
implementation of the API and for
example when you cannot description to
the types so in this case declaring what
the string is but you can do this with
any type and this one also allows you to
do testing like this so you can use
autocomplete and you can basically
explore the API and and tested which is
super powerful because you don't have to
do much work to put this in practice I'm
gonna show a bigger demo nicer change
okay so I was only talking about
quitting now so this is how you do a
queen graphic read so you can specify
the operation type which is Queen in
this case and then an operation name
which is only used for debugging
purposes so for example you can of logs
with all the operation names and then
you can specify the fields that you want
and this is the extended version you
don't if you're just doing a quick you
don't have to pass query and the name so
you can do are we listening before but
if you are not for example I did data
you can use mutations which they work
the same so you have a name the
operation typed and a name and you can
also pass arguments for example in this
case we are passing an argument or ID to
the Edit category mutation and then we
are passing a hard-coded title in this
case and then we fetching the data
so basically mutation they basically
work the same as quiz so the same syntax
and the same result so you can also you
can do a mutation you can request for
the data that you want back it doesn't
have to be a different data it can be
what you want then the other one is to
me it's very interesting is subscription
so it's an easy way to subscribe to an
event happening on the backend so in
this case we can subtract an event
called on category update and every time
some this event is called we get the
data back only the days that I requested
so it's really powerful this yeah one
way of declaring this value need for the
operations and there's much more there
are tools that I think I'm big gonna use
where I work now to basically build an
API gateway so you have one single
gateway that's talking to different
actual API s and then it's gonna
basically do the API calls for you so
for example if you have a user micro
services and a post microservices
and you are asking for user and the post
is going to do a equally to both of them
but for your client for your front and
this is turned transparent which is
really powerful and if you work with
front-end there are clients that make
dealing with graphical really you don't
have to do much thank for example I
wasn't meet up a couple of weeks ago and
there were they were using there was a
company that was using grass and they
were saying we spend about two-thirds of
our time on the front and dealing with
data so fashion the data normalizing
it's starting in our temporaries - and
then showing it on the front end and we
have Carol the first three steps are
basically already done for you because
use a client you defined it that you
want and then you get it back and if you
want to see some example in the front
then you can talk with me later
oh yeah we use Python and we love Python
and I think Python syntax is really
beautiful and especially with feyten 3
with the additional features that we've
seen like for example type-ins which I
think it's my favorite feature in Python
3 so tie pins are basically a way to
annotate functions and variables and
glasses with types and Nicky knows these
types for example as a you can do type
checking so you can check if your
function is being called by the correct
variables and you can also use this a
runtime using tools like imports where
you can say I want this function to
raise an error if the type that's being
passed is wrong and this it's know why
usually one place useful in some cases
especially if you're dealing for example
with external api's anything's to be in
control and you cannot resource so
things like my PI seed it's optimizing
and you're kind of compiling the code in
a way using the type annotation as a
hint and then the other feature that I
really love it's called data classes
which I think it's been inspired by
others if you know the emergent and
basically using type-ins to allow you to
create a data container so across the
only old data in a very simple way so
this this decorator what is doing is
cutting out the fields that you see
there so here and not Indies and then is
creating the init method representation
method and other methods which you use
for like sorting comparing companies in
this case and it's very powerful because
in before lines you've done something
and you do here with 39 and Python in
graphical I mean if this if you've seen
it this the previous data classic and of
looks like a graphical type so in this
case we have same class which Collier
apart and then there are two fields and
the
the type so IQ in a library called
strawberry where you can use this
decorator consumer type which is
basically doing what other classes is
doing just actually using data classes
and the dude is also creating graphical
type so you can use this and create a
server Munda so yeah the library's
called strawberry and reason why I
created it it's mainly because I wanted
to have fun and learning so I wanted to
to experiment with basically create in
your library think you know how could
people use this out to make it easier to
use and also the reason is I want to
experiment with new feature because
graph QL is quite new in Python and we
are still not when if you've seen if in
check javascript there are so many
libraries and they are doing so many
cool things though I think it's worth
telling them in Python as well
especially because python is much nicer
than JavaScript I went too fast and also
the other thing it's really one improve
the ecosystem so we now have four
libraries one when I started this we had
two libraries one was in production but
I wasn't it wasn't really updated over
time so I think having other libraries
that try new things we can share
experience we can basically cross
pollinate in each other with ideas and
improve the old ecosystem hopefully so
how does it work as I said it worked we
tie pins and data classes so let's see
an example this is the schema that we
had before so we had menu item category
as you can see in maps one two one two
to fight them more or less but yeah as
you can see there is no way we're not
fetching any data here so I was thinking
of the past data there are two options
so one is to kind of pass a function to
to the fields but the other option is
this one which kinda looks like a
property in Python so you use a
decorator this case strawberry field and
then it's using type-ins again to
basically understand what's the type
that's been returned so this is creating
a field on the on the Queen called
categories the returns a list of
categories but you can also get a
massacre
is argument so in this case is doing a
fetch of the categories passing either
10 or whatever the limit that we pass to
the argument and gonna show them on this
quickly so yeah this is what we had
before so again we can get a list of
categories
then for each category you can get the
items
and so basically this it's like 20 lines
of 500 this which is quite cool and you
can also specify arguments 2d to the
fields so I think this is one of the
most popular thing in in graphical so in
this case it's only sorry I'm returning
a one category and it's really powerful
because for example you can have a field
that can return for example the heights
or something or the dimension of
something and you can specify the unit
so it can be like using a metric system
on the imperial system and you don't
really have to do different points or
passing filters get parameters
so yeah the current features are it
supports a thing so you can do I think I
your stuff so it supports subscription
which is using I think I yeah so it's
really simple to build a something that
I'm listening to pops up and sending an
event back to the to the serve to the
front end supports mutation queries
there is a debug server that kind of
works doesn't really work with anything
because it's been massive I didn't
really spend much time on it and then if
support for a ski huskies a synchronous
implementation of whiskey so it's
basically a Swiss keep upward-facing and
I think a ski trade basically means I
work with any husky server so you can
use select you can use respond Baca
daehyun's on and soon just I'm trying to
work on the docks I got bit stuck with
the design because I really like things
that really nice to look and then when I
have a design I'm gonna finish that then
I want to make it stable so we're gonna
use this hopefully for if you know
pattern Italia we're building a new
website and we probably gonna use
strawberry for for the API and that
means I have a production project where
I can test this and make it stable so we
want to have jungle support friend of
mine is doing jungle support which
should be ready
hopefully in less than a month then a
photo tracing which is basically a way
to do matrix analysis on on graphical
api's because it you don't have it's a
bit different you can for each resolver
you can track how much time I filled it
it took to load and then fill permission
which is going to work similar to
junglers very murky for me familiar with
that you can specify a subclasses on
each specific individual field and then
you can validate for example if a user
can see the field and so on which I
think it's really powerful because
allows you to Teresa typed and without
having to worry to for example without
having to create a public user and a
private user you can basically check for
example in the email you can say oh I
only wanna see the email if the user is
the current user or he's an admin which
is really powerful so I really want to
see more people using graphical in
Python
it doesn't really matter if it's my
library or and you'll gather three so
graphene if you wanna use character
right now in production the the only
library that works and it's been using
productions graphene then there are the
other three so strawberry is the one I'm
working on and then there is Ariadne and
30 fret and they they're new and they
take two different approaches so they
use instead of writing Python to the
final schema you write the schema as a
string was a file and then you can
attach resolver functions basically to
to your types to your fields so it's a
different way of defining schema
I recommend check them out because they
are really really interesting and there
are different ways of doing the same
thing in each it could fit what you're
doing more so yeah and that's let's go
and build better API I think I think as
web developers we we should focus on
creating api's that really is easy to
use for our developers or front-end
people or client people working on
mobile apps and but also api star really
user friendly so if you had a don't
waste data for users API don't yeah
don't don't waste the bandwidth and the
CP of user because yeah we I mean we are
now in Switzerland and like everyone
that's coming outside they're using
roaming and roaming most of my friends
they have to pay for it and it's really
expensive so even in first world
countries we still have issues be like
data being expensive so that's fine
being paralyzed yeah my name is Patrick
all the information out there that's my
Twitter handle if you have any questions
happy to take them thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Patrick so we have any
questions please come to the microphones
yep I have a question thanks for a good
speech and I have a question as a
back-end developer or system
administrator let's say we have a
graphical end point implemented and on
production and I noticed that I have a
huge load on my database and what kind
of tools do I have in graphic oil to
investigate that situation because for
using rest I can try to find what calls
were made and what data was retrieval
but for graph QL it may be maybe it can
be a little covered yeah there is there
is a lot in Python there is not much
though so why you can do especially if
using caffeine and junghwa there is a
tool called graphene junga optimizer
which is basically analyzing the query
that's being received by your back-end
and is trying to do
federated select related for you the
other things would be to implement a
middleware that's doing the the tracing
support so you can send information to
data dog or maybe the Apollo tracing
server but right now there is nothing
built into graphene or any other library
there are other things you could do to
you to improve for me there are kind of
workouts you can use data loaders so
basically is a way to kind of postpone
the fetching of some information so for
example if you're fetching I don't know
like a list of blog posts and for all
damn you fetching the user as well with
a different way you can get the list of
ID's that you fetching and then doing it
later so when you know all the IDS that
you need you can fetch them and so you
don't do and +1 query but yeah we can
also talk about
and that just there's a lot any other
questions
okay hello thanks for the speech so I'm
new to graph QL I would like to know how
do you connect this with your database
because this is not everything to me mmm
okay so connecting I mean it's like REST
API basically you have an endpoint where
you do that data as a data fetching and
then you're returning so you have
pointing functions where you get the
data I need this for each field that you
have in the new API if you use something
like jungle if it's jungle or sequel are
coming you can use graphene which has
graphene jungle graphene sequin arcing
where you can get a jungle model or
cyclic remodelings converting to a
graphical type and so you don't have to
write the graphical typing again but you
still have to do a decrease yourself
there is also some tools like there is
support for jungle filtering graphene as
well so you can plug down and it also
gives you argument so you can do
filtering on the front end
any questions
don't be shy
okay we have one question
can you go into a bit more detail of the
differences with the graphene and why
why you had to do something new okay so
when I start this in October when
graphene was so basically the main
maintainer of graphene stepped down and
it was basically working around the
project but the problem was that he
didn't give access to maintaining the
graphene 21 so basically was a moment
where I was doing progress I did a
couple of requests like Django rest
framework support for graphene it's
something I've done yeah I was trying to
inter contribute by there was a lot of
friction because basically no one was
able to merge stuff I think now in April
we got access to github and pi pi/2
publish things so now there's people
working on it I'm trying to work I'm
focusing this many on this aside also
because I want to experiment new feature
and try different way of doing things
any more questions okay
thank you for a talk I was just
wondering like how you feel about schema
first development versus like the code
first
yeah so as I mentioned the first to our
schema first that's our code first and
the other to our schema first I prefer
code first especially because I said
like Python is really nice to write and
like especially with strawberry you can
reuse types you can reuse data classes
that you already have prop them as a
graph QL type and it works and you get
out of compression on the stuff while we
schema first it's a bit different it's
it's this is my personal preference
under like schema first there are there
are people that like them especially
there are libraries thing des and I
think I don't like writing things twice
because you have to write the scheme and
then you have to touch it and you need
to be sure that also you're doing things
in the right way because if you mistype
some things now it's not working but
yeah it's a matter of preference I guess
yeah I mean there might be some cases
where you actually I don't think can
think of any but there was someone
building a dynamic schema and they
needed to do schema first because they
had like a scheme as a string so we
concatenating together but I don't see
that being something common Thanks
okay
other questions
okay Thank You Patrick
[Applause]